today's question is so why do critics
use the phrase we the audience rather
than just saying we or the audience well
the phrase we the audiences really
intended to kind of be a reminder of
sort of asymmetrical knowledge when
you're looking at a movie as a audience
member typically the balance of
knowledge between what the main
character knows or what the
point-of-view characters know and what
the audience knows is fairly well
delineate 'add though every now and then
you end up in situations where either
intentionally or unintentionally you end
up with a disconnect or a fairly severe
disconnect between what the characters
know what the point-of-view characters
know and what the audience knows so the
phrase is really meant to call attention
to that relationship that it's like that
whatever example is to follow is going
to highlight that this is something that
we the audience understand also from
just a writing perspective as a critic
it's an opportunity to remind the viewer
or the reader that like this is
something like that that the critic
themself is also a part of the audience
and that you know we are on essentially
the same level of engagement with the
with the text as each other as opposed
to the critic being something holy set
apart from from the average viewer as
always the best way to reach me for a
question is through ask fm or Twitter
links down below in the description